alexis bonjour le gouvernement castex a
donc présenté un plan de relance de
l'économie de 100 milliards d'euros
est-ce que vous avez été convaincu par
cette présentation à ce que ce plan va
se montrer efficace selon vous ça reste
à voir j'ai été peu convaincu par ce que
c'est un plan de relance qui utilisent
les vieilles recettes c'est-à-dire qu'il
est question de faire beaucoup de
cadeaux aux entreprises parce qu'il faut
éviter les faillites massives en ça
c'est plutôt bien essayé de préserver
l'emploi mais quand on voit les échelles
100 milliards dépensés pour une création
de 160 mille emplois seulement alors que
on parle de millions d'emplois qui
pourraient disparaître d'ici la fin
d'année
donc on peut se poser des questions il
ya ce cadeau bien sûr sur les impôts de
production pour faire un peu un nouveau
cice en fait un pacte de confiance avec
les entreprises
mais comme le disait jean marc sylvestre
le problème c'est qui va consommer quel
va être en fait la reprise au niveau
mondial pour permettre à l'économie de
reprendre donc ce plan et bien ils
oublient en plus un pan social
extrêmement important extrêmement réduit
seulement 200 millions d'euros qui sont
réservés au plan de lutte contre la
pauvreté et l'exclusion
c'est très peu quand on pense à tous les
gens qui vont perdre un emploi et
peut-être se retrouver à la rue suite au
confinement et suite à la crise issue de
cette pandémie alors la priorité absolue
reste l'emploi en croire jean castex le
gouvernement penche sur la suppression
de huit cent mille emplois cette année à
cause de la crise économique liée au
commis le 19 mai il prévoit la création
de cinq cent mille emplois entre 2021 et
2022 est ce que c'est réalisable
c'est sans doute réalisable mais ce sont
des emplois extrêmement volatile emplois
aidés de nouveaux emplois aidés un peu
comme sous le quinquennat de françois
hollande
surtout pour aider les jeunes 750 mille
jeunes qui entrent sur le marché du
travail et pourrait bien éviter que le
chômage ne soit encore plus massifs dans
cette tranche d'âge mais il y a un effet
de seuil puisque ces mesures visent
surtout les moins de 25 ans mais qu'est
ce qui va se passer pour ceux qui ont
plus de 25 ans et pour les travailleurs
plus âgés qui risquent eux de ne pas
retrouvé d'emploi et de rentrer dans le
chômage de longue durée
donc c'est un effet assez court visé
aussi avec une visée électoraliste bien
sûr puisqu'on parle de 2021 2
22e l'idée c'est que les chiffres ne
soient pas catastrophique en 2022 au
moment de la campagne présidentielle
pour que le bilan de ce gouvernement est
bien puisse être défendue par emmanuel
macron s'il souhaite se représenter
donc c'est une campagne déguisée avec de
l'argent public pour sauver des emplois
mais encore une fois 100 milliards pour
cent soixante mille emplois
c'est peu et puis ce gouvernement refuse
à créer des emplois dans le secteur
public
on avait entendu un indiscret qui disait
que le chef de l'état ne souhaitait pas
embaucher plus de trois mille
professeurs parce que c'était pas des
emplois qui servait à la croissance mais
on n'est plus dans une économie de
croissance on est dans une économie de
récession de dépression même pas avec
l'inflation qui risque d'arriver aux
états unis est là et bien on continue de
faire comme si la croissance allait être
au rendez vous or tout ça c'est une
inconnue parce qu'on ne sait pas quel va
être le niveau de reprise de l'économie
mondiale
alors ce plan de relance c'est aussi la
part belle à la transition écologique
est ce que c'est une urgence justifié
selon vous oui parce que là il ya
effectivement des bassins d'emploi et il
y à un besoin
ça permet à la france c'est bien de
tenir les engagements de l'accord de
paris on est quand même sur des temps
très long on parle de neutralité carbone
en 2050 on qu'on laisse le temps aux
entreprises polluantes et bien de se
verdir comme dit barbara pompili
ministre de l'écologie mais là encore
les mesures restent à être scrutée à la
loupe que que va-t-il être mis en place
réellement pour verdir une économie
massivement peu lente
on parle aussi des do particulier pour
la rénovation des logements notamment le
thermique
pour éviter ces passoires thermiques qui
font qu'on dépense trop d'énergie en
france c'est très bien mais là encore ça
permet à des propriétaires aisés bien de
remettre aux normes leurs logements pour
faire une plus value lors de la revente
il n'y a pas de plafond de revenus pour
ces aides
donc on va aider ceux qui n'ont pas
forcément besoin quand les gens qui
voudraient investir pour se sevrer de
cette rénovation thermique ne le font
pas parce qu'ils ont d'autres priorités
donc cette question de la relance par la
consommation elle est vraiment crucial
et elle n'est pas résolue par ce plan de
relance
alexis poulain merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
notre éditorialiste